okay well first of all i saw on the gram
that y'all three got
matching ghost tattoos oh we did
were you guys sober when this was
happening okay can i see this i haven't
got
mine yet it was just it was purely a bad
decision
but no i get out of here it was a great
decision we got it done at like one of
the best studios in new york and we were
all meeting up in new york to do it and
we made like this
really cool like broadway trip at the
same time and then
and uh no it was it was awesome we were
100 sober
and it was fun and i was there the whole
time but my uh my my fiance at the time
wife now was like
she didn't give me the go ahead on the
tattoo so i was like all right
we'll work on it you're getting one
i don't care if i have to pin you down
right yeah we'll hold you down we'll
have to like stick and poke it'll just
be a small little smiley face but
you know or the ghost emoji just a
little yes so his ghost cat is literally
a ghost like we can't see it it ain't
there
oh there you go okay there you go
exactly i like invisible i'm gonna start
you there
um so you guys you guys seem like y'all
get along
so well you seem like brothers
really did you guys hit it off when you
first met
yeah owen was like flirting with me when
we first met and i was a little weird
so i was like not gonna lie and then and
then it ended up being
just really friendly so um yeah
done from there six week intensive
helped where we were together for eight
hours a day
we're forced to be friends but you know
really cool guys
and sometimes you get into situations
where you know you don't have the
friendliest people or like
people that are too easy to collaborate
with but uh these guys in madison
they're so so supportive and some of
that comes from kenny you know always
kenny preaches like um this he's gonna
create a safe space where you can try
things and
and and you won't get embarrassed and um
and and that was huge and i i think
there's just a lot of support going on
with cast
yeah yeah i agree and it's uh literally
i mean charlie and owen roommated
in in canada when we were shooting even
though i was in the same uh
in the same apartment any time that we
were offset if i wasn't just sleeping in
my bed i was over there playing video
games and hanging out with everybody so
we spent all day
every day together i saw that you guys
also met kiss
during rehearsals yes oh my god
yeah kenny's like hey guys so um my
friends next door
uh they're uh they would like you guys
to come say hi and
would you guys like to go and we're like
yeah of course they're your friends okay
let's do it
and then we walk in the room and it's
kiss and then
the show drops and then kenny sends us
this um this email saying like i've got
it dude
i've got it i'll read it read it read it
this one says
uh right here it's from kenny yeah and
it says
from paul stanley kenny let your cast
know that they are
all invited to the next kiss show they
will be my guest
and can see the show from a special area
are you
joking me oh my god i have the chills
that is so dope oh we might get tattoos
after that one too
yeah jeremy you're gonna have to hit
your wife up and let her know like yeah
come on
i'm gonna get her on board oh my gosh so
obviously you know charlie you and
madison actually wrote a song together
perfect harmony
um what's it like just knowing that fans
are just jamming out to your music
it's the craziest thing literally the
craziest thing like like
the whole thing like from day one it's
like you've grown
so much as a band like we were put
together but then we started working
together on our instruments and
everything and it's like
what's the next step what's the next
step and the next step was
let's write a song if we're going to be
a balance let's try to write and so
and julian luke in the story they're
always writing music for the series so
then by the time like
we were like sneaking off set and the
boys knew this it was just us for like
we were like
it was like five minutes like for a
break and then people were like oh yeah
crafty crafty so like we'd
run away and then hide off like i had my
my acoustic just like chilling there
and uh and we just like played for a
second try to figure out something and
we talk and we have these conversations
about like what is drew
what is luke feeling what is julie
feeling and uh
and then now people are listening to it
it's rise in the charts like like me
our album's number three right now on
itunes and it's the craziest thing in
the world
wait are you guys going to turn this
into like a thing after like outside
this show
like is this going to be a thing oh it
looks
suspicious we're going to pretend we're
going to pretend like yeah
maybe whenever yeah we want to go on
oh my god we want to go on twitter to be
able to like interact face to face with
like
uh the people that have given us so much
love so much support already on the
fifth day is like mind blowing so
to be able to see them that that would
be like a really cool dream it's so cool
it's only been five
days five days charlie jeez
louise oh my god yeah they want us
they're already saying they're like two
or two or two or like yeah yeah yeah
yeah and kenny kenny wants it too um it
was so
nice talking to you guys i knew this was
going to go by really quickly
oh my god we're already done i know i
should go get a tattoo too one more
question go for it one more question
um no i don't think i'm allowed will i
get in trouble okay well
um do you guys believe in ghosts yes
yeah why not why not we play them on tv
why not right
i mean i don't know but sure it's very
possible
yeah you guys okay well that's fine guys
have the tats so it's
fine no no ghosts are definitely the
walking earth like you
feel them when you're around like you
see them sometimes i swear
ghosts exist
okay i like it thanks guys i appreciate
it
awesome have a good day